[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever we what we
got him surprise I'm finally bad dude I
just you know I've been around out and
about featuring Tim DeLaGhetto you know
going international I see you were in
New York I was in New York for a bit but
let me see how this story that's cuz
I've been waiting okay earlier what did
you say earlier but I think my dad died
we were all just talking about random
[ __ ] and he just ran in he's like yeah
well yeah and then he's like yeah I
think my dad died but then dooby-doo
voice like that doesn't think his dad
died of coronavirus by the way so it is
there's no connection to anything that
we're talking everybody's like yeah good
cards later or like what this we're
about to come down on my and then I was
like wait do i what do I so we don't
know that your dad is dead yeah and we
hope that he's not nah
but we were both sick like for a month
that's why we were texting back and
forth and it he's top 60 cuz the way
that I'm RIA is anyways but yeah so what
what did that make you remember say it
reminded me of this one time in high
school when like everybody was freaking
out cuz they were like you know
something happened to one of the
teachers he had like he started
seizuring and he passed out everyone saw
his after school was like holy [ __ ]
what's going on like it's really like
the vibe was tense right so my boy
Cam'ron he literally walked up to me
like this like you're me what something
he's like man my boss did you just die
[Laughter]
I was like crank it up but yeah he died
yeah yo I get the sitcom oh my god I
wasn't kind like tangi who happened to
miss her whatever it was I can't man
like I don't know if he's meeting me
like he started Ceaser heat his head on
things oh my god yeah yeah it was when
he like passed that little buggin yeah
electrocution [ __ ] and then hit his head
on like a table or something that was
really good school special a fan Wow
Joe's having a seizure we waited that
long it was his fault check this out
look what just happened okay what
happened was you guys see this right
here
right here okay in the middle of it all
we were kind of late to start and I was
like me and bar have this surprise and
we wanted everyone to go because we set
up a bar for everyone and yeah I had to
cover that [ __ ] cuz I wanted to unveil
it you know but Ryan was out here trying
to fix the Wi-Fi so I was like man you
got to be a part of this too so then we
got everybody out and then he thought I
was waiting for a story and I said [ __ ]
your story Tim right now we have
something important to do
he made me think that because I was like
I was waiting for okay so one time and
he goes hold on and I was like oh damn
okay Joe has something to do but he
really wants to hear my story real life
sorry tom all right cool that's waves
look at those quiet Gio's making like
awkward like explain what's here what
you're what's a new TV show you're
watching build an awkward socket not
gonna segues she was trying to find it
funny Joe comes out of the room and he's
like all right guys come over here I'm
like brah I'm sorry Tim I didn't know
that's what I did okay I'm sorry
it's okay you know I wanted to know your
story okay but here's the thing
everyone's been [ __ ] killing it so
damn well for the past month I don't
know if y'all seen the energy it's been
completely different on JK news you're
welcome
yeah yeah music here I agree we add you
and I think you know I think thanks guys
ya know in the comic they're saying
forgetting Tim into here the best guests
recently because you guys are really our
friends I know and so that's all and
everyone else isn't right and it seems
like no when they're here I mean even I
mean that's fact okay they can feel the
energy like no that's that's completely
true because when I do the podcast or
when I do videos and collaborations with
other people I will rarely do it with
people with new people you know I'm
saying like I'd like to invite people I
actually know real life people I'm
friends with and when my podcasts like
the people that kind of produce it when
they're like hey you know we have this
person we think might be good for your
son like oh no it just kind of throws
off the vibe because we've had
celebrities here we had people with like
because had weapons here birdies that's
true villain honor a great honor it was
a downer not an honor we had people that
have like way more subs than us - it
just doesn't work out with this fan base
I think what they care about is our
actual friendship the chemistry yeah
everything but it's been really really
fun so I'm like alright what can we do
to make them even happier that to be
here let's get them [ __ ] drunk so
they'll never leave true and it's been
working for the last month it's like not
even sending him and we all took a
shower right yeah we did it was fun yeah
I don't drink early man that that's
pretty crazy for me but but it's
definitely it's just a cool car battery
thing I think yeah I wish I could join
in on it like I always do you guys
cheering so fun I know
but still not the same because I don't
have the same substance you guys out on
the side same little buzz that everyone
asks cuz I do feel it for like two
minutes and then the passing out of my
car you you know you are burgers like do
you remember what being drunk feels like
just pretend that your daughter I [ __ ]
the beach you [ __ ] a beach bar you
know you are your you're the Virgin on a
reality television show you know it's
weird though this this has been a pretty
non-alcoholic company for a long [ __ ]
time like we would smoke weed together
before we would drink together
yeah and it's because we all all the
people that can't drink kind of found
each other I always kind of knew you
guys as like you know as the group that
wasn't really drinking like the carnage
yes and people think we're like the
opposite yeah darling you ready for some
coke [ __ ] bro that's the thing man the
best people to party with are the ones
that you know yeah they're fun when
they're under the influence but they
don't need to be under the influence to
have a good time you know I'm saying and
for the longest time I remember going to
parties and being completely sober and
like people being like to me my group of
home he's been like damn how [ __ ] up
were you guys right now like did we're
chillin yeah we're fine it's fine you
know well and we don't I mean this group
really doesn't do drugs so people do
assume they're like hey man you want to
[ __ ] get [ __ ] up as [ __ ] and then I
I say a lot of [ __ ] to so people are
like Steve I cuz I'm very Pro drugs and
[ __ ] but I don't personally do that yeah
so then people are like oh well Steve
drinks so is he down to [ __ ] and I'm
not when people ask you if you wanna do
drugs are you do you already say yes but
you just say no out of your mouth I wish
coz I always say no but I actually
really want to do it and I'm like you
just got to ask me why two more times
it's enough dude so you're going like
this no I don't want to [ __ ] do
cocaine it's straight up if I wasn't so
[ __ ] paranoid I would do it sure
would but but yeah I'm too paranoid ya
know I've never been a drug person I've
never even done anything aside from now
maybe one maybe one day bro maybe with
you I can't do it anymore
I guess all right because you want to
learn I'm traumatized but I don't have
good memories anymore
hmm you want to hurt no it's scary yeah
it has to be the perfect circumstance
cuz I heard this speech from Joel before
where I know I've been traumatized I've
known her for a long time right and then
we went to his buddy's party remember in
arts district and in somehow he doesn't
remember yeah so we were kicking it and
then we all we were on he was giving us
a tour from the pool on the roof we went
into his room and then his buddy was
like hey you guys want to sniff this
aerosol from this whipped cream for just
all-time sake Joe Joe was like nah I
can't be doing anything and then I'm
like and I was looking at him like
Nigel's not gonna do it and also [ __ ]
like sniffing I have no memory of such
such claims dude that's like all guys
getting together and being like hey they
just don't make batteries like they used
to delivery and it's like I found it old
battery we can do we can do acid like we
used to like that is [ __ ] wild I
don't think they do to me I think judges
needs the perfect nudge is the perfect
match for context of circumstance and
anything can happen maybe it might be
right I've never done anything aside
from a little bit of marijuana yeah you
know but that I said that about weed I
was like I'll never smoke exactly cuz it
I I went through a really dark time but
then when we smoked in Vegas that just
opened up the door was that your first
time away a long time yeah in a very
long time I think I had a it had to be
almost like an eight-year break yeah
yeah I feel like because I've done
adderall I did diet coke if that makes
sense because it really is very
accelerating
yeah meets adderall I never tried it I
mean we should all do it especially
since like so it helps you like focus
right very much so all of us have like a
TV and we just take it and we become
chill yeah if you can if you're a person
who can already focus on something and
do and do something okay
then it's that can resume out on things
if you're gonna get like carried away
easily then I don't think adderall is
for you because you can just start hyper
focusing on 17 things at once and then
your [ __ ] stuff take it to figure out
which one you are what also depends on
dose gotta figure out how to get it cuz
Nicki throw away by and so I inspired
got prescribe what you are prescribed
[ __ ] no I got it in Mexico oh and
they're all yeah I feel like an adderall
is the choice of drug for people in
entertainment for sure
I think it's cocaine yeah me too I will
not will that work on set Oh
photographer really yeah yeah I'm kind
of telling people on that all editors
editors oh okay well they're not in
front of the camera yeah it's for a TD
people hmm I didn't realize how popular
cocaine was up until like well years ago
I realized oh [ __ ] cocaine still like
pop in you know I'm saying cuz when
you're going up watching movies you
think oh cocaine just something to do in
like the 70s and [ __ ] it wasn't popping
when we were in high school no but it is
now actually that's not true either
because when I was going when I went to
a Catholic school for one year my
freshman year this deer this Jeep full
of like white boys cocaine a ziploc bag
full of white powder maybe it was
[ __ ] bakin Soder they were [ __ ]
with me but I was at the stop like about
to go to school and he's like white boys
drove by and they're like [ __ ] yeah held
up this bag of powder I assumed oh it's
cocaine that sounds like a prank I can't
believe you thought that was real why
are drug people so cool that's what
that's what that's what drives me crazy
right that's what that's what the
religious people did so poorly is they
tried to brand drug people is not cool
and I'm like you guys [ __ ] up yeah
they're cool as [ __ ] they'll literally
talk to you like no matter who you are
and they're like yes
[Applause]
you know you want some drugs ah just so
nice and sharing it [ __ ] you know how
many friends I've made on just weed
alone back in like junior high
mmm like that was I think my gateway to
socializing yeah cuz it was like oh
you're gonna get we're gonna get stoned
you want to come over yeah this gets out
everyone pitching some money and then
everyone smokes
sometimes yeah it's all sticky and [ __ ]
see how many rich people do you know who
come on with the kick wads of cash yeah
I know people who do cocaine in high
school cuz I was always curious and I
always wanted to try it and they're
always so greedy
really weird maybe this is expensive
they're like nah probably maybe they're
at that point of I'm hooked now and I
just need this to survive in the very
early stages it's everybody party let's
do this together later on it's like I'm
not gonna tell you have anything as I
knew and I offer food yeah anybody want
any but if I see people start taking a
lot of them like come on dude dude you
hate someone comments you definitely
gotta like secretly take bumps of gum
because everyone's gonna be on that [ __ ]
and I get one I remember when I first
heard like realizing cocaine was really
popular I was just talking like a tiny
home girl like she was like a little
innocent home girl in my house I was
like man it's crazy how probably their
cocaine is out here like these days I
was like yeah that's crazy she's like
cuz it's awesome I'll say oh [ __ ] you
see coke no it's immediately tempted to
take coke um drugs just kind of like
scare me you know I'm saying I smoke
crack and the one click you said on
episode of JK one time of that you about
your crack experience and it made me
legit he described I would never sell
crack so I'm a great salesman yeah so I
could make a lot of things you know what
you said you know he said that you were
like I smoked crack one time and he's
like it felt like my whole body every
nerve in my body was getting massaged
for ten seconds oh that was it
good pitch I like Hornets out of me
that's a pretty good that's a really
good pair you might be in an alleyway
with the person pissing on a [ __ ]
dumpster while you have a girl glass
pipe that you're lighting up with foil
and you might feel like a disgusting
piece of [ __ ] but for 20 seconds of
heaven they beam you out of that space
and you forget that you're there good
and then you have little cells just
massaging each other the whole entire
body you frozen in time if people ask
you questions they'll be like hey man
were you gonna eat something later ha
and then you stop for 30 seconds and you
go huh huh sorry you're done pissed and
[ __ ] myself
what were you saying it's scary how dope
that sounds it is crazy I was reading
about how heroin feels so it's supposed
to feel like your mother and Mother
Nature gave you a hug and there's
supposed to be this where all of your
walls and inhibitions and you're just
completely vulnerable it's the most
awesome feeling and feel-good feeling
could ever feel in the world I'm really
curious and I want to try all drugs but
that's the one I like a mother's love
assumes and cocaine I can live my life
without knowing what that feels like
I'm super curious about sure yeah I
haven't done shoes heroin and cocaine
let's do shoe what about damn cheese
I'll do DMT with you guys cuz I listen
to the Joe Rogan experience a couple
times but ayahuasca or diem stomach
what about DMT does that give you the
ships girls and [ __ ] isn't that DMT
makes ayahuasca makes you puke yeah it
makes you puke that's what I've seen on
your Netflix specialist net jumping out
there the ayahuasca is is cocaine the
one word that makes Alex Jones go hey
choke me out Eddie took me hot man who's
that no one owes you talking about oh
yeah they do the guy that got banned on
you guys is bad for everything took me
out Eddie yeah
released I don't give a [ __ ] Jesus to
choke me out
that shit's amazing I had a homegirl
tell me about shrooms and it made me
curious cuz she was like she was like it
will make you
acknowledge and appreciate things that
you would normally just gloss over like
she said she was like she was on
shooting then she was walking by like a
garden and normally you just walk by
some flowers like whatever maybe they
look whatever but she was like oh my god
these were the most beautiful flowers
I've ever seen am I made out with a
dandelion yeah yeah she like stuck a
sunflower or two per day whoa whoa like
it was going there though well yeah look
man that sounds really great and the
fact that I feel like it's natural yes
people do say they feel more sensitive
and more into and a feel of more loving
when they take that Oh see some stuff
sup hating on heroin out there everybody
stevegrace some hating on [ __ ] heroin
pow
what do you can you get even get shrooms
at a dispensary or is it still illegal I
would he get shrooms that there was
dealer there's a city somewhere that
legalized shrooms all right no not not
here oh it might have been Colorado oh
yeah they did I'm sure we can find it
easy probably changes her name to
something funny yeah go to the forest
and find him you know you can literally
text PD flow and know you got it you
can't just go find the right one no you
got to go to a word there's a lot of
cows that girls on cow [ __ ] cows key you
know it all get all girls on cow [ __ ]
damn there's pretty nasty don't do drugs
cuz it's made out of [ __ ] I don't know I
was watching this video be like damn
drug sounds tight yeah it is tight dawg
you just control the mountain I'm like
as long as you can control yourself and
it doesn't consume you I can't
experience it I'm like cool but at the
end of day if you're high on life you
don't need to take other things to reach
another level of happiness
nothing beats a blow job though that's
facts okay I wish that way I wish we
were all in front of a big amphitheatre
full of children who are sitting
indian-style right now
drugs nothing beats a [ __ ] thank you
very much we have a children's book
alright second page the hungry caliper
log [ __ ] bases all right I used to have
a book called a penis pokey where it was
like a book where it's like a hole that
you could every picture was like one
would be like your dick would be like an
alien's nose
turn it and another one be like a cowboy
riding your dig and like and your dig is
the horse where do you get this buck
from I just got that you know like
Spencer's or don't you have to keep
taking your dick out to turn the page
what yeah yeah yeah you go that's the
way it's like when it's like chilling
when it's like chilling you just take it
out and it goes like I see you've tried
it both ways
what a limp dick so what are you exactly
what it's a win you're a wreck you can I
gotta like you know should go to the
hole than if it's limp hit the like well
yeah Geo but we're used to that that's
fine yeah
listen to the hole yeah what we do
that's what we do is man thank you I'm
scared of drugs
I'm never got fun I'm never gonna go
back to that do you think that drugs has
carried over into maybe your speech
patterns and into the way that you are
in general I sure feel like I'm like yes
wait you guys she was before
oh how about damn [ __ ] crazy and like
we're girlfriend was describing or your
homegirls yeah um I like the flowers and
everything yeah my psyche everything
looks so dreamy and like it just looks
like so vibrant and colorful and you
feel like you're poor it's really nice
calm down
is there a calm down hey you get the
shit's and it's bad it's bubble good
really bad like the calm down is so bad
I would never do it again
I only yeah speaking of oh [ __ ] the
video is almost over you gotta play the
outro song
[Music]
beautiful every time
[Music]
[Music]